what are we doing the name mystery robot
I don't know how to copy that that's
good enough
[Music]
so weirdness studium here's the Becca
we are visit Houston guests they invited
us over to check out what Houston has to
offer this is so exciting I've only been
to Houston once before and that was for
like a one day or like two days how long
were we here for just like super quick
Christmas road trip stopover and so we
didn't really get to check out much
other than the NASA Space Center but it
was like really packed because I was
during Christmas time but apparently
we're gonna be going tomorrow we get to
see things that we didn't get to see
last time at NASA and then there's like
this whole itinerary planned out for us
that visit Houston created for us and
it's gonna be way excited baby
yeah countly fun oh no in it at the
front desk they left us a gift too so I
wanna see what because an astronaut
that's so cute
oh yeah I think you've been told
into the space buffer now he recently
bought a video game with a call Kerbal
space program yeah how do you play cuz
it looks like it's a really educational
game so I totally approved it there's
three modes but one of the mode of
sandbox and you get refined Rockets up
to different planets or you can just
splash it in the air inside of ducky
yeah so you're pretty much doing like
aerospace engineering video game for
video game for I'm so cool so I'm like
is super educational so this is cool we
got a bunch of shoes man we have take
over your Mustang
it's all yours like houston we ran the
moon oh he's somewhere in the woods is
that what they say so having breakfast
right now they're about to pick us up
pretty soon and then we're headed to
space but yeah so they have a waffle
maker here and so we made two waffles
I'm almost done with mine Isaac pretty
much done with him I was just telling
Casey we've been traveling so much to
places where it's like more I guess
exotic and it was kind of refreshing to
just sit down and have like a good old
American breakfast good ol America so
we're gonna finish up breakfast and then
you
[Applause]
[Music]
with that the fans are lucky because we
actually have to live it but then they
could just see it in like two seconds
that's true where are we baby we're used
to Smee sinner who is it skipping time
guys comment down below I know huh baby
have to sit in a long car ride like us
hey no but yeah we're back are you
excited about the private tour you know
what they said that we might be meeting
an astronaut today yeah didn't catch
that oh you liar you little liar no baby
that's the Texas flag dad blue cute give
you first American flag and Texas flag
together somehow that is the Puerto
Rican flag again oh and then another
thing I want to point out look at how
empty this parking lot is behind me the
last time we were here we can't even
find a parking space huh do it so Pat
yeah it was so so packed last time we're
here so this is gonna be a different
experience for sure I burned my tongue
that's why I'm thinking a little bit
weird oh it looks way cooler when it's
empty
and it looks a lot bigger because last
time we were here looks smaller huh yeah
do you think it is with all the people
like there was just like clumps and
Clemson Clemson Clemson lots of people
oh yeah you did get a nasty shirt last
time we were here we totally forgot to
bring it huh does that mean we have to
buy another one I don't want to
necessary
hey you're ready to fly the jet you just
designed you guys got really cool chairs
[Music]
I had some camera shakes to make it look
more intense you're so ladylike sitting
so politely
[Music]
okay Tony Stark which ones have you baby
earth or Mars Garrett do you know why
it's heavier
yeah you got it
so heavy
so 30 pounds away our lowest 10 pounds
apart other cool if there's one day in
the year is so crappy like rowdiness all
that be careful but now what if we lose
all of our stuff and face
or you could like control the gravity
Holly is like a little lever where you
could be like no gravity like I salute
you no gravity or like half gravity or
thirds one day in the year just it's
like a natural what like a natural
disaster or like a yearly event fourth
of July very excited to meet the
astronaut we're doing that next I know
that's a cool question I want to know
too happening we get to have private
time with the astronaut before they open
the doors that's so cool
I feel special I don't know about you
how was it meeting as astronaut this is
where they would have their drinks does
it remind you of anything
Mexican candy oh yeah the Lucas where
you squeeze it yeah my mouth just got
watery I'm craving some now yeah that's
my mouth what is that dragonfly I like
her it's a video dragonfly you're like
running away from it
this is so different because the last
time we were here I was breathing and
now I am burning
oh my gosh like the cameras Arcanine are
condensated or font restricted here yeah
[Music]
that's an ASBO either floated in oil or
a specific material to actually keep it
buoyant
oh look baby anywhere discusses aviators
nice wow this is cool you want to fly
somewhere all right astronauts and their
families ready to get the show I know me
neither this is such a cool experience
no no no don't touch anything we're
gonna take off huh do you feel that
we're taking off Isaac you started
something astronaut we met that guy look
he made it out to you yeah looking I got
one with my name on it
like fun ways my voice is so monotone
yeah even when you did use some pretty
fast arithmetic and some algebra you can
actually use em but it's useful to
understand as much mathematics as you
can so the more you can get yourself
into the mathematics the better you'll
be with some of the engineering or
physics or even the chemistry how much
time did you spend how much time that I
spend in space 3 missions probably less
than 30
well I'm sure less than 30 days but you
know they were spread out over several
years so it wasn't like today where
you're up there for six months and then
go back again for noticing when you
suggest a different recipes how are you
getting on the trail where to Mission
Control Vivek
and they saved us beasts
[Music]
[Applause]
I was just telling Isaac I can't imagine
like all those spaceships building your
game Isaac
imagine you got to build real life space
rockets like oh you're doing it right
now in your game but like this every
kind of scary to test it huh with real
people in there getting tired aren't you
yeah the heat is pretty exhausting huh
yeah oh I want to switch with Daddy like
you did in Puerto Rico
it looks like rocket huh meeting a
former astronaut I'm getting mastered
some cool question
[Music]
and it's super hot its like 19
exhaustion like 93 degrees and it's very
very humid but it's the summertime we do
you expect true true this is a normal
summer everywhere else in the world
we're just super just degrees if it's
colder than that it's - it's freezing if
it's higher than that it'll burn it up
we're really peppered in soca but now
we're in Houston and we're enjoying the
Houston Houston weather haha how do you
feel baby I like it you like your like
the different types of weather boiled so
cowboy but anyway we're about to ride
some ride and then later on we're having
dinner
I like your skis very 90 whatever I do
you want to ride first
oh really can you even write it by
yourself check it out
it's all enough oh man you're like way
taller than tall enough
do you want a writer wait for your daddy
for me
[Applause]
you have to pick it wouldn't be an easy
answer because you know your mother's it
[Music]
doesn't actually give you but it's
pretty cool claiming we're gonna get on
this that's the line that wants to get
on look at you little thrill seeker like
your mama I think are you ready yeah
you're nervous
I love the nervousness you get right
before right here you take the camera
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey hey I do and shut these braces that
look I took my retainer out no I quit
the law crooked if you're watching this
video and check you from playing check
if I'm playing Kerbal space program and
tell my future so I said look this guy
is huge
you guys hey man you got something on
your stomach let me get that for you
oh no that circles head overnight let's
go have dinner now for the shot guys
um ooh and now maybe Dabba Dabba Dabba
she'd you know that song I know it's
such an old reference I'm an older
[Music]
morning yeah I'm like uh I'm with you
man I'm pretty tight wind asleep pretty
late cuz Isaac was having a blast at the
boardwalk riding rides huh baby so
today's a new day we're gonna be doing a
bus tour of the city we're gonna get
some cool sightseeing of the city of
Houston no I've never actually done any
like touristy things in Houston here and
I grew up in Texas in Dallas and every
time I come down to Houston it's always
like family stuff and we never do like
what the city has to offer so you're
never come on into Houston you they have
never flown into the airport before
either so I was like this is the first
and it's like the first I've ever been a
Houston like as a tourist as a tourist
yeah so that's pretty cool baby I love
your outfit look at this
he's mr. Pizza Pizza back back to me
cutie banane there's a piece of boy up
and then I have a pizza
yeah look at this nice red shorts and
those grace shoes Walmart actually all
somewhere except effect
[Music]
means so much but I think that I'm sorry
I think that you're part of it in me or
something would you want to go to that
not for extra Houston Museum of Natural
Science you're gonna learn Brin Pandora
I match my shirt you should do it you're
attracted to me I know you're attracted
to me you match my shirt okay cuz I'm
wearing orange shirt actually they were
matching we should have tracked all the
orange butterfly
[Music]
if you stare at them long enough they
look kind of alien ish I got afraid
which I named them
[Music]
or what they're fighting
[Music]
what are you doing now we're enjoying
downtown Houston blue and a few dozen
stab the deputies you know that's all
eyes ik no I already asked that's my
favorite song for the longest time - I
loved it I remember I came out when I
was making the I forgot which grade but
it was elementary school yeah I'm
entering Cathy knows like third grade I
would sing that song in my head when I
was playing with my action figures I was
like this song is doper than the Mortal
Kombat song there she used this sounds
like ghosts in the tour guide I was
talking about beyond saying how Houston
is her native town because she was
saying like you know if you go to this
spot you might bump into fiancee V but
oh that's about you might bump bump into
fiancee here like would Beyonce and I'm
like you don't know what Beyonce Queen
Bey alright quick quiz
who's jay-z rappers oh so you do know
jay-z way nosy yeah this is our last day
in Houston we leave today around 6 p.m.
our flight takes off so right now we're
gonna drop off your luggage at the bell
desk cuz we have to check out and then
we're gonna go have some barbecue
we can't leave Houston without having
barbecue brisket when I first said
barbecue I think the screamer
how cute you thought it was Korean BBQ
BBQ different all right so first camera
business at a barbecue spot at the Texan
must be the briskets
oh that smoke ring that's beautiful it's
very very very tender a lot of barbecue
places tend to try out their meat by
this boys in peach cobbler alamode so
what you want to do is you want to get a
little bit of hot peach cobbler and a
little bit of cold ice cream and eat it
together
BAM magic in your mouth okay good
[Music]